[Music]
some 200 million people voted in the
European Parliament elections and one of
the first acts of the new Parliament is
to elect the next European Commission
president he you leaders have proposed
German Defense Minister Ursula von der
Leyen
von der Leyen is a member of the party
that won the most seats in the European
Parliament but she didn't take part in
the lead candidate process and will have
to work hard to win support from members
the day following her nomination von der
Leyen travelled to Strasbourg to meet
the parliaments new presidents and the
political groups saying she wanted to
earn their trust in Parliament the
process is totally transparent she will
have to lay out the programme for her
presidency before the whole European
Parliament before members vote on her
candidacy the debate with the members
and the vote will be streamed live
[Music]
if von der Leyen is elected the
selection of commissioners will start
immediately Parliament will hold
hearings to judge if they are up to the
task
members will then vote in plenary on the
entire Commission
if von der Leyen does not get banking
from an absolute majority of MEP s the
European Council will have one month to
propose a new candidates
[Music]